le concours de beauté des mini-miss
aura-t-il lieu la question est grave
pour l'instant c'est la guerre des
comités miss france qui fait rage et qui
prolonge ce suspense insoutenable deux
présidents pour un comité c'est trop et
il fallait régler ça devant la justice
olivier levasseur 15 ans et au moins
autant de procès depuis plus d'une
décennie le comité miss france a deux
présidents deux équipes à la tête d'une
même association qui élisent chacun de
leur côté une miss france un imbroglio
juridique qui se compliquent depuis que
l'un des deux protagonistes a créé un
autre défilé celui des mini-miss
habillée avec soin les enfants défilent
comme leurs aînés et concourant
plusieurs tenues devant un jury
d'adultes seule différence mais de
taille la plus âgée n'a pas huit ans
c'est une récréation c'est un jeu pour
les filles est mon 4 à 8 ans et un d'un
créneau d'âge où il ya un petit peu
l'inconscience donc ne sont pas du tout
traumatisés au contraire elles viennent
pour gagner des cadeaux
on leur donne des cadeaux même si les
organisateurs s'en défendent l'idée est
donc plutôt commerciale et intéresse
davantage les parents que les petites
concurrentes
beaucoup de gens s'insurgent contre
cette forme de défilé et bien sûr
l'autre concurrente du défilé miss
france je ne vois pas comment on peut
mettre des jeunes des petites filles de
4 ans 5 en maillot de bain de les faire
défiler devant plutôt 10 messieurs et
comment juger une petite fille en
maillot qu est-ce qu est-ce qu est-ce qu
on peut juger d'abord les enfants sans
boutons sont tous bons naturellement
c'est ce qu'ils mangent victime d'un
préjudice moral madame de fontenay veut
donc interdire l'élection de la mini
miss france demain à paris cet
après-midi la guerre des miss
connaissait donc une nouvelle bataille
au palais de justice